hey i have a question brittany which is
you can read people how do you think i
would do i've never skydived before
if i came to sign up and you knew me or
you know me as well as you know me
how do you think i would do i think you
would do okay i mean you're very tall so
that's a big consideration because you
have a lot of like a lot more body than
i do so you can control the wind more um
oh
so that's a plus
uh it's a plus if you do it right
but like if you're like if you're on the
front of me and you're doing all sorts
of crazy stuff you're gonna outfly me
you know so you have to really well i
would be flailing a lot yeah right now
right i mean i'm just telling you right
now i'd be flailing and i'd you'd be
behind me right yes and nobody could see
me because i'm small so right now you're
telling me they wouldn't see you people
would think i was parachuting alone i'm
so tall and yeah
for you
right but here's i can tell you a few
things for a fact one my arms and legs
would be flailing wildly okay
uh i would be shrieking and not like not
like a yeehaw shriek
but a a shriek of impending doom right
right crying and i would be trying to
reach back and claw at you i'd be trying
to physically claw and attack you
because the fear part of my brain which
is not reasonable would be blaming you
and wanting to kill you you know what i
mean that's just that's just honest
that's just honest no i get it and you
know what the honesty is helpful because
then i can prepare for it and just like
knock you out before we get out or
whatever yeah you should bring men you
should bring us you should it would be
your first dive that you ever did with a
powerful syringe of horse strength
yes
right and just to get out the door
when i would land now i when you land
how hard do you land i i've heard it's
like you can hurt yourself when you land
it's like you're going it's like jumping
off what a 10-foot wall or an eight-foot
wall or something so not anymore um back
when we jumped with the round shoots
that's how it was um but now
they fly a lot more forwards there's a
lot of forward speed um and we just
slide in on our butts and it's actually
quite soft okay okay i think in world
war ii a lot of people they jump out of
planes and they break their leg when
they landed because if you didn't do it
just right it was nasty but now it's
going straight down and what's your
biggest fear of something that you might
land in accidentally when you land let's
just say you get blown off course what's
the thing you would least want to land
in so
i have never had this experience but
other people have if you land in
you know you look for a field if you're
not going to land at the airport and
sometimes there's bulls or like other
aggressive animals and apparently that's
not a great place to land can you
imagine
being a bull and you're in a bad mood
anyway and then this jackass just falls
out of the sky and lands and and knocks
over your water trough
so do they that can you you land and
then you're attacked immediately right
right exactly like you survive the
skydive and then you get killed by a
bull oh i would try i would love to if i
got blown off course i would want to
land at a big festive occasion like a
wedding that was pretty
because everybody gets so excited to see
you well i also i'd want to smash into a
bunch of stuff like that
you know
i would love to
land on someone's wedding during a
pretty important part smash into the
cake
uh knock over all the wine right slam
into the you know the bride and the
groom
just you know what i mean
and then and then and then get up and
act like you guys ruined my skydiving
joke right right
yeah that's what i would do if you come
to a tandem with me we can find a
wedding and we'll do that okay you know
i have never gone skydiving before and i
have to admit it terrifies me but if i
did it i would want to do it with you i
really would thank you no you seem very
cool and i would trust you 100
and
you also seem very uh very funny i think
we'd have a good time well thank you i
think we would too yeah i want to
reserve a slot with you if i do it okay
all right i'm not saying 100 i'm going
to do it no that's okay
pretty sure i'm going to make i'm going
to do something embarrassing it's going
to be embarrassing the flailing and you
know the flailing and the shrieking and
you're probably going to make i know you
you're going to have uh one of those
gopros on yes and you are going to get
all the footage of me begging for my
life cursing you out
shrieking the crying yeah yelling at god
saying i i blame god right um yeah just
completely breaking down as a human
being becoming a child babbling crying
soiling myself
and then you would probably you would
put that online i know you would well
yeah it would go viral so